(instrumental music)
- Woo, my man Paul got a date!
- Yeah, sure.
- Um, whose dish is this?
- It's mine, it's just
one, please don't trip.
- Mo, get the dish, that's nasty.
- Hey man, I thought
you'd be more excited.
You know it's been a
long time since you...
Bro, come on man, you gotta move on.
I'm serious.
- What if I don't want to?
- Then you let her win.
- Mo, get the dish.
- (groans) Don't let her
win, Paul, don't let her win.
- But she's all I need
in this life of sin--
- I'll stop you right there,
that lyric only applies
if she were your girlfriend.
She's not your girlfriend, she cheated.
- Exactly, and I don't think that "sin"
rhymes with "conniving bitch," one time.
- Good one Mo, hey get your dish.
Paul listen, forget about your ex, okay?
Go out with Samantha,
she's a really nice girl.
Get the dish.
- Dish.
I ain't getting no God damn dish.
(upbeat music)
- Alright girl, what you want?
- I want one of those finger things.
- Alright, you'll get a finger.
- (laughs) This is rigged.
Is that it, did you just
get it on one chance?
- You want another one?
- Yeah.
- I'm toke'd up girl, I got the tokens.
- Skittles guy or Starburst guy?
- Starburst guy, I choke on skittles.
- Me too, right here.
- Okay.
So what's your favorite game, Samantha?
- Any of the shooting games.
- There's a basketball game over there,
you pretty good at that?
- I'm amazing, I'm gonna kill it.
- I don't know, I'll beat you.
Kobe!
Okay, sorry, alright.
You wanna shoot another one?
- Oh my gosh, it's just one
dish, let it sit in the sink!
- Bro, that's how it starts, just one!
"Oh, we only lost by one state's vote."
"Oh, we're just splitting one atom."
"Oh, it's just one boat
off the African shoreline!"
- How'd you even come
up with that comparison?
- I don't know, I saw
George Simon doing it on TV.
- Dude, I am freaking out.
Christina just called me, does
she wanna get back together?
I don't know what to say.
- Nothing, you say nothing.
- Wouldn't it be weird if
I'm just quiet on the other
side of the phone?
- Paul, she called you by accident, man.
Under no circumstances
do you return that call.
- But what if--
- No!
- Alright, alright.
- Okay, so where'd you guys end up going?
- The arcade.
- Ew, did your moms drop you off?
Are you guys gonna go
to the make out point
and touch each other?
You ready to finally
talk about that next step
of sharing lockers?
It's not a dish from Beauty and the Beast,
it's not gonna get up and walk away.
- Oh really, because other things of mine
have gotten up in this house
and walked away apparently.
My iPod, my Mya CD.
- She got the best of me!
- Another one of my favorites.
- Nice, you play hockey, right?
- This is different.
- It's kind of the
same, it's very similar.
I don't know if we should be playing this.
- It looks dangerous and I'm kinda scared.
- Let's do it.
Oh!
(upbeat music)
(buzzing)
- Hello, Christina?
- Hey, what's up man?
Yeah, yeah, the arcade over..
No, the other one.
Yeah cool, alright, bye.
- Hey, are you okay?
You were acting kind of weird in there.
- Mhm.
- Well I had a really great time.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Hey, you need a ride home?
- No I'm good, I got my
board, I'll skate home.
- Okay, well I guess
we'll hang out again soon?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Okay, well thanks again.
- Bye!
(jazzy music)
- Can you give me one second?
Hello?
- Hey, you needed me?
- Um no, you called me.
- You called me earlier,
I was just returning it.
- Hey Paul, I have to go.
Bae's about to perform and...
Sorry, it was probably a butt-dial.
Take care of yourself, okay?
- Yeah, you too.
- If you just practiced
putting your dishes away,
then we wouldn't have a problem.
- We don't have any problems.
- Oh not yet we don't.
- Oh, we never will.
Paul, do you have a problem with this?
- No, just one dish.
- Just one dish!
- Okay, you guys are not seeing
the bigger picture here, right?
That muck is gonna get harder and harder,
then you have to let it soak,
then you have to buy
extra strength dish soap,
then you have to go to therapy.
All because you can't get rid of something
you could have gotten rid
of a very long time ago.
- Oh God.
You called her didn't you?
- I just got here.
- Hey, while you were
busy living in the past
did you see who shot JFK?
- Good one, Mo.
Get the dish, please!
I'm losing it, get the dish!
(jazzy music)
- Hey Samantha.
Sorry about earlier.
- Quick question, do you have any coke?
- Like Coca Cola?
(calming music)